Claude reynol c'est pas un changement
politique peut-être j'ai peut-être y
réfléchir à essayer de cette séance qui
est dans l'avion de qui nous rejoint
depuis Toulouse donc son avion est en
retard et donc provisoirement je vais
essayer de le suppléer pour salut le
rapporteur général Éric Lombard bien sûr
mais les chers collègues on se fait tant
de bonne de mon vœu pour cette année
puisque nous entendons ce matin donc
Éric lobar qui est le candidat proposé
comme vous le savez par le Président de
la République pour être reconduit dans
ces fonctions de directeur général de la
Caisse des dépôts et consignations et
évidemment la Caisse des dépôts est
consignation aux yeux du Parlement et du
Sénat est une autorité particulière
puisque la Caisse des dépôts est placée
de la manière la plus spéciale sous la
surveillance et la garantie de
l'autorité législative et à l'instant
Eric Lombard me rappelait que sur le
fronton de du porche côté de la Seine il
y a écrit ordonnance de 1816 qui
rappelle cette autorité particulière du
Parlement
menti et les exercer notamment par la
commission de surveillance
à laquelle siège deux collègues du Sénat
plusieurs parlementaires dont Jérôme
bacheld pour notre commission
et Viviane artiguelas qui est également
présente qui est pour la commission des
affaires économiques si vous souvenez
depuis la réforme avant c'était
uniquement commission des finances
d'ailleurs depuis votre première
nomination en novembre 2017 nous avons
eu l'occasion de vous entendre de très
nombreuses reprises dans vos fonctions
directeur général notamment chaque année
en commun avec la Commission des
affaires des effets économiques et cette
édition évidemment ce matin d'un format
un peu différent puisqu'il s'agit de se
prononcer sur votre reconduction je dis
je rappelle donc en application la loi
organique et la loi ordinaire du 23
juillet 2010 relative à l'application du
cinquième et lumière de l'article 13 de
la Constitution à l'issue de cette
édition nous voterons afin de confirmer
ou d'affirmer le choix du président de
la République je rappelle également que
terme du cinquième Alina l'article 13 de
la Constitution le président de la
République ne peut pas procéder à une
nomination lorsque l'addition des votes
négatives dans chaque commission
représente au moins 3/5 des suffrages
exprimés au sein des deux commissions et
donc le dépouillement sera effectué
après votre addition par l'Assemblée
nationale en fin de journée et donc
enjointement nous aurons donc le
résultat donc cet après-midi
je rappelle également à tous les
collègues que cette édition est publique
et qu'elle est également retransmise en
direct sur le site internet du Sénat
alors je vais pas loger de propos vous
allez je crois comme vous en avez
l'habitude puisque c'est la deuxième
fois que vous prêtez cet exercice vous
livrez si vous le souhaitez à propos
préliminaire et puis ensuite
Jean-François Usson notre apporteur
général vous interrogera et puis
puisqu'il est je propose je crois que la
Commission la désigné comme rapporteur
pour cette édition et ensuite bien sûr
les collègues qu'ils souhaitent pourront
poser les questions qui souhaitent à
Eric Lombard avant que nous procédions
au vote dans la foulée comme ça nous
serons libres pour les réunions de
groupe merci beaucoup je vous passe la
parole en étant très heureux de vous
entendre
merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président Claude Reynald
monsieur
alors j'ai un problème de protocole donc
monsieur le Président albéric de
Montgolfier
donc
je suis je suis
je suis très honoré par cette double
président
général Jean-François Husson monsieur le
sénateur commissaire surveillant chez
Jérôme bacheler madame la sénatrice
commissaire surveillante chère Viviane
Artigalas et un grand merci d'avoir fait
cette escapade en dehors de votre
commission de rattachement mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs je suis très
honoré ce matin comme l'a dit albéric de
Montgolfier de vous présenter ma
candidature au poste de directeur
général de la Caisse des Dépôts puisque
effectivement le 8 décembre dernier le
président de la République a proposé de
me reconduire pour un second mandat et
je vous demande aujourd'hui de bien
vouloir m'accorder votre confiance
effectivement comme le dit Albéric
demande Gaultier au-delà de la procédure
prévue par l'article 13 cette rencontre
se traduit dans ce qu'ils font le rôle
de la Caisse des dépôts et sa relation
au Parlement parce que vous le savez
c'était dit par le sénateur de
Montgolfier nous sommes placés sous la
surveillance la plus spéciale et la
garantie de l'autorité législative et
croyez bien que pour l'ensemble des
femmes et des hommes de la Caisse des
Dépôts cette relation avec le Parlement
de la nation et quelque chose de très
fort et de très quotidien ce statut
unique se traduit naturellement dans
notre gouvernance pendant 5 ans nous
avons été présidé la commission de
surveillance a été brisée par Sophie
errant puis par le sénateur Jérôme
Bacher que je remercie à nouveau et
qu'il a fait avec
l'énergie et les compétences que nous
lui connaissons et puis depuis le mois
de septembre par Alexandre allroyd
cette relation particulière j'ai essayé
de la faire vivre en vous rendant compte
régulièrement et comme les prévoient la
loi pacte au-delà de ces réunions
auxquelles j'ai participé beaucoup de
mes collaborateurs sont très souvent
parmi vous pour exposer le suivi de nos
affaires alors je vais commencer
évidemment par dire quelques mots de
bilan et peut-être dire que il me semble
que la caisse est aujourd'hui plus forte
plus efficace au service de nos
territoires et de l'économie
premier objectif de mon action était de
rendre le rôle de la caisse plus lisible
auprès des élus et c'est pourquoi nous
avons créé en mai 2018 la banque des
territoires qui regroupe depuis sa
création l'ensemble de notre expertise
et de nos offres à destination des
territoires et sous l'implication de
l'ivier sechel la banque des territoires
est aujourd'hui le point d'entrée unique
pour vous mais pour tous vos collègues
élus qu'ils soient situés en zone rurale
ou dans les métropoles qui soient
situées dans l'Hexagone ou dans nos
outre-mer son organisation est très
fortement déconcentré décentralisée
puisque plus de la moitié plus de la
moitié des décisions sont prises dans
les régions au plus près du terrain
l'offrey globale ça commence par de
l'ingénierie car pour un projet de
développement il faut d'abord des études
afin que ce projet soit ensuite bien
mené et puis des investissements en
capital en fonds propres et des
investissements en prêt pour finir de
financer les investissements qui sont
proposés et si on parle des prêts je
veux rappeler notre activité historique
de prêteurs sur les fonds d'épargne qui
nous a permis notamment dans la période
d'accompagner les importantes mutations
du logement social avec notamment deux
plans logements et puis un effort
particulier pour la rénovation thermique
de notre parc et puis à cet égard en
termes de logements social je veux
évoquer notre filiale CDC habitat qui a
le premier bailleur français très engagé
notamment dans la rénovation des
copropriétés dégradées
je profite de cette occasion pour redire
mon attachement au financement par
l'épargne réglementé en fait les fonds
d'épargne constitue un modèle absolument
unique de transformation de l'épargne
populaire qui est une épargne à court
terme garantie auprès de très long terme
puisque nous allons jusqu'à 80 ans et
comme vous savez les conditions d'accès
à ces prêts sont exactement les mêmes en
tout point du territoire en tout point
du territoire ce qui fait que c'est un
outil absolument massif d'égalité
territoriale c'est la seule action
financière qui en réalité soit
complètement équitable quel que soit
l'endroit du pays où nous nous trouvions
les résultats de la création de la
Banque des territoires sont tangibles je
veux juste donner un chiffre depuis 2018
le volume des investissements réalisés
en capital sur les territoires a été
triplée et il atteint l'année dernière 2
milliards d'euros et ce montant est
d'autant plus important que nous
générons un fort effet de levier compte
tenu de la confiance attachée à
l'institution et quand nous investissons
un euro et bien il y a 7 euros
d'investissement privé ou public ou
venant de l'Union européenne grâce au
projet investiou qui qui nous accompagne
depuis le caractère complet de notre
offre nous a permis de participer à des
opérations importantes je pense à action
cœur de ville au service de 222 villes
de métropole et des Outre-mer à petite
ville de demain dans les zones rurales
et à territoire d'industrie
le second axe du renforcement de notre
ancrage sur les territoires c'est
l'opération de rapprochement avec la
Poste qui était autorisé par la loi
pacte en 2018 est réalisée en 2020 grâce
à cela la caisse sados a un réseau sans
égal évidemment en devenant majoritaire
de la Poste nous sommes engagés à
accompagner sa transformation mais
également à nourrir de nombreuses
coopérations stratégiques et j'y
reviendrai
cette opération avec l'acquisition de la
fil a fait de nous en fait un grand pôle
financier public acteur majeur du
financement de notre économie et
ensemble nous disposons de 1300
milliards d'euros de ressources qui se
traduisent en 1300 milliards
d'engagements le chiffre est vraiment
massif 1300 milliards d'euros
d'engagement au service de l'ensemble de
nos territoires et je veux préciser que
depuis la création du Grand Prix
financier public entre la Banque Postale
la banque des territoires fil qui est
spécialisé en financement des
collectivités locales et en financement
export et BPI France et bien les rôles
sont bien précisés
l'action est vraiment bien segmenté
entre ces différentes entités de façon à
ce qui est pas de gaspillage d'argent
qui à la fin et l'argent des Français
je suis également très attaché à ce que
nous faisons en matière de politique
sociale j'ai voulu renforcer la
direction des politiques sociales vous
savez que nous gérons la retraite d'un
Français sur 5 au travers de la CNR ACL
et de l'ircantheque et puis nous avons
connu un développement important en
mettant en œuvre au cours du quinquennat
précédent mon compte formation
mon compte formation c'est véritablement
une révolution de l'accès à la formation
professionnelle d'abord passer la
massification puisque des millions de
Français ayant eu accès mais surtout
pour une meilleure équité de l'accès en
fait auparavant la formation
professionnelle c'était pour caricaturer
plutôt pour les cadres masculins
aujourd'hui c'est majoritairement pour
les employés pour les ouvriers et c'est
paritairement pour les hommes et pour
les femmes donc il y a un accès à la
formation professionnelle beaucoup plus
représentatif de ce que de ce qu'est
notre société
et puis et bien nous avons été au
rendez-vous des crises c'est notre rôle
contracyclique et j'étais venu vous
présenter notre contribution au plan de
relance
26,3 milliards d'euros de fonds propres
aux côtés du plan de relance mis en
place par l'État et je suis heureux de
vous dire aujourd'hui que conformément à
l'engagement qui a été pris à la fin de
l'année 2022 nous avons engagé 80% de
ses sommes et naturellement nous allons
finir la mise en oeuvre de ce plan mais
nous avons voulu que ces fonds soient
engagés le plus vite possible pour
soutenir notre économie
alors tout ce que je résume très
rapidement à la volée devant vous
n'aurez évidemment pas été possible sans
l'engagement des femmes et des hommes de
la Caisse des dépôts et je veux devant
vous les remercier leur rendre hommage
parce que ce sont des personnes
extrêmement professionnelles qui sont
sur le terrain tous les jours au service
de l'intérêt général avec talent avec
engagement avec énergie et ceux qui
évidemment chaque jour font de la Caisse
des Dépôts ce qu'elle est
enfin ce dynamisme a permis de dégager
aussi de bons résultats économiques
c'est essentiel pour une institution qui
n'a pas d'actionnaire et qui est placé
sous la protection du Parlement on l'a
rappelé puisque nous avons dégagé en
moyenne sur la période 2,5 milliards
d'euros de résultats ce résultat compté
après un équivalent impôt sur la société
que nous versons et vous savez qu'il y a
une règle tradition qui veut que nous
versions à l'état une part de ce
résultat
dans la période nous avons versé à
l'état 6 milliards d'euros 1,5 milliards
d'euros par an donc la Caisse des dépôts
est aussi un contributeur important au
budget de l'État et c'est d'ailleurs
c'est un rôle citoyen qui nous honore
alors un second mandat pourquoi faire
bah ce moment-là si vous le décidez et
bien notre solidité financière une plus
grande efficacité au service des
territoires cette transformation interne
nous permet de nous projeter dans les
cinq prochaines années et nous prenons
nous prévoyons d'investir 27,5 milliards
d'euros c'est à dire rester un rythme
d'investissement qui est au niveau de
celui que nous avons connu pendant le
plan de relance en effet nous sommes
convaincus que l'expertise les moyens la
qualité des femmes et des hommes de la
Caisse des Dépôts vont nous permettre
d'accompagner la transformation du pays
autour de trois axes prioritaires le
premier c'est la transformation
écologique
le deuxième ce sont les souverainetés et
le troisième qui est une continuité mais
qui reste tout à fait centrale qui porte
sur la cohésion sociale et territoriale
alors je commence par le premier axe
celui de la transformation écologique et
c'est un mot que je préfère à celui
transition car en réalité c'est toute
notre économie et toute notre vie
sociale qu'il s'agit de transformer pour
faire face
au réchauffement climatique et assez
défi et je veux dire ici que ce défi est
aussi source d'investissement de
transformation et j'en suis convaincu de
bien-être pour nos concitoyens et donc
il faut le regarder positivement mais
cette transformation écologique elle
exige des investissements massifs
des investissements massifs que nous
avons commencé puisque depuis 2020 nous
avons déjà engagé avec des pays France
50 milliards d'euros et nous comptons
dans la période 2023 2027 engagée si on
ajoute aux investissements capital les
financements 80 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires alors rapidement
quelques secteurs d'information de
d'investissement d'abord j'en ai déjà
parlé la rénovation thermique nous avons
déjà en 5 ans engager la rénovation
thermique de plus d'un million de mètres
carrés de bâtiments publics la
rénovation thermique de près de 190 000
logements sociaux mais naturellement le
rythme doit s'accélérer et pour cela
nous mettons aussi en place des outils
et je veux juste en citer un devant
votre commission l'outil priorino qui
était monté grâce à un accord avec les
énergéticiens et qui nous permettent de
donner un élu un bilan énergétique des
bâtiments de sa commune et de lui dire
par exemple dans les priorités de
rénovation qui doit engager faut-il
commencer par rénover le gymnase faut-il
commencer par rénover l'école nous
donnons aux élus grâce à priorino la
consommation d'énergie des différents
bâtiments et ainsi peut planifier la
rénovation qui veut engager au cours de
son mandat et que naturellement nous
pouvons financer sur les fonds d'épargne
et puis il y a les mobilités durables
d'abord les transports publics nous
pensons que les transports publics
doivent être ouvert le plus au plus
grand nombre dans le plus grand nombre
de territoires de façon évidemment
totalement des carbonée et par exemple
nous finançons avec l'Union européenne
l'électrification des buts de la RATP
mais aussi les bus à hydrogène à Dijon
ou les bus électriques à Brest et nous
pourrons demain être le financeur de
nouvelles infrastructures avec les
petites lignes ferroviaires sur
l'ensemble de nos territoires ou les RER
métropolitains qui peuvent irriguer des
grandes zones métropolitaines
aux bornes du groupe nous avons une
filiale de transport public Transdev qui
naturellement à elle aussi engagée la
décarbonation de son action
et puis avec la Poste nous avons créé
des outils particuliers movie Volt qui
peut accompagner le verdissement des
flottes des entreprises et
Urby qui accompagne la logistique
décarbonée dans les métropoles
et puis la décarbonation des transports
c'est aussi les transports individuels
nous allons faire ce que nous avons fait
toujours dans les grandes
infrastructures de notre pays financer
l'installation d'un réseau de bande de
recharge électrique et c'est quelque
chose qui est important qui va pas être
facile notamment dans les zones rurales
mais nous y travaillons et qui est
également compliqué dans les
copropriétés parce que naturellement le
premier qui s'équipe ne veut pas payer
pour tout le monde et nous avons pour
traiter ce sujet mis en place une
filiale dédiée le givolte et qui
fonctionne très bien
mais malheureusement vous le savez les
effets du réchauffement climatique sont
là et nous devons aussi accompagner
l'adaptation notamment des territoires
les plus fragiles je pense aux
territoires littoraux et au territoire
de montagne et nous intégrons cette
dimension d'adaptation dans nos projets
urbanistiques je pense à la réduction
des îlots de chaleur dans les quartiers
politiques de la ville notamment et à la
renaturation alors j'évoque la
renaturation parce que je n'oublie pas
que avec le réchauffement climatique va
aussi les risques pour la biodiversité
et le maintien de la biodiversité nous
l'assurons au travers de deux types
d'actions d'abord notre filiale CBC
biodiversité dédié à cela et qui fait de
la compensation en matière de
biodiversité mais aussi en exerçant
pleinement notre métier d'aménageur qui
en réalité se transforme complètement
parce que l'aménagement Deauville est
d'ailleurs de nos campagnes doit
complètement changer pour respecter
l'impératif écologique réduire
l'artificialisation des sols et nous
savons combien c'est un défi pour
beaucoup d'élus construire ce qu'on
appelle la ville sur la ville et par
exemple faire de plus en plus ce qu'on
appelle la seconde vie du bâtiment et la
permettez-moi de vous donner un exemple
la seconde vie du bâtiment c'est quoi
c'est au lieu de détruire un bâtiment et
de le reconstruire qui consomme beaucoup
de ciment et je rappelle que c'est les
cimentiers étaient un pays ce serait le
septième émetteur de carbone de la
planète donc le fait de garder les
structures de béton c'est une grande
économie de CO2 et par exemple la
Villeurbanne ce que nous avons fait
c'est que nous avons reconstruit des
bâtiments en Gard l'infrastructure ce
qui est plus coûteux mais qui est qu'un
homme en carbone et ce qui a permis en
l'occurrence de recréer des bâtiments
qui au lieu de vieux HLM sont devenus
des bâtiments neufs à énergie positive
donc à tous égards un bilan carbone
favorable et donc toutes ces nouvelles
méthodes de construction et
développement sont absolument
essentielles évidemment nous les
accompagnons
et puis la sobriété foncière nous impose
également de modifier l'organisation de
l'espace urbain et nous avons un projet
de travailler sur les entrées de ville
il y a dans nos entrées de villes
beaucoup de centres commerciaux qui en
réalité vivent moins bien depuis que à
la fois on a pu redynamiser le
centre-ville et ça on en est très
content ou il y a aussi la concurrence
du e-commerce et nous allons transformer
petit à petit certains de ces espaces en
nouveaux éléments de ville à la place
des parkings à la place des grandes
boîtes à chaussures que nous connaissons
pour recréer de la diversité en termes
de logements et d'activité
alors il n'y a pas de transformation
écologique sans une mutation profonde de
notre système énergétique et c'est le
deuxième axe des priorités que nous nous
fixons des souverainetés énergétiques
mais aussi industrielles numériques et
financière sur l'énergie évidemment le
contexte géopédique que nous connaissons
nous invite à plus d'autonomie
énergétique et là aussi nous pouvons
jouer un rôle majeur la Caisse des
dépôts et coactionnaire des deux grands
réseaux transports d'énergie en France
RTE avec EDF et GRTgaz avec engie et
d'ailleurs nous pouvons plus largement
financer toutes les infrastructures
lourdes qui sont devant nous
ça c'est pour la distribution nous
sommes aussi
un producteur d'énergie d'abord énergie
hydraulique puisque nous sommes
correctionnaires de la Compagnie
nationale du Rhône et là il y a aussi
des développements qui sont devant nous
et puis nous intervenons dans
l'implantation de parc éolien en mer ou
sur terre ou de centrales photovoltaïque
je vais juste donner deux exemples parce
que toute notre action est territoriale
la centrale de Labarde à Bordeaux plus
grande centrale photovoltaïque établie
en ville en Europe donc sur une ancienne
décharge sans artificialisation des sols
et puis je veux signaler cher Jérôme
Bacher dans un département qui vous est
cher les travaux que nous ont sur la
base aérienne de Creil
où nous installons des panneaux
photovoltaïques sur une piste en béton
donc à nouveau sans artificialisation
des sols
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
vous promets je ne citerai plus le
sénateur pas cher
au total
au total la banque des territoires
finances déjà 8 Go soit plus de 13% de
la capacité de notre pays alors nous
sommes prêts à faire beaucoup plus pour
financer les transitions augmenter nos
investissements à travers un nouveau des
fonds d'épargne des fonds d'épargne
c'est quoi c'est l'épargne populaire
c'est l'épargne du livret A c'est
l'épargne du ldds c'est l'épargne du
Livret d'Épargne Populaire c'est un
formidable outil de transformation je
rappelle que les encours de ces fonds
c'est 500 milliards d'euros dont 350
milliards d'euros gérés par la Caisse
des Dépôts c'est une sorte de grande
empreinte permanent et c'est fond vont
être mis à disposition des politiques
énergétiques que vous allez décider
parce que évidemment ces choix relèvent
du Parlement de la République
et puis
la transition
l'indépendance énergétique va de pair
avec l'indépendance industrielle la
souveraineté industrielle certains
esprits avaient fantasmé des entreprises
sans usine et là aussi le contexte
géopolitique l'évolution du monde montre
combien ils ont tort et pour moi qui
suis
issu d'un vieux département industriel
l'aube vers la sénatrice polygagen qui
on est originaire aussi ça m'a toujours
paru un fantasme absolument irréaliste
l'industrie c'est la base du
développement économique c'est la base
du développement territorial mais
naturellement il faut que cette
industrie soit une industrie décarbonée
donc la Caisse des dépôts est très
engagée dans la réindustrialisation de
notre pays que nous devons moderniser et
ça passe par un travail sur la
réhabilitation des friches la
construction d'une nucléaire en main et
vous avez sans doute vu cette semaine
les annonces du ministre de l'économie
et des finances en matière
d'industrie verte et naturellement nous
allons accompagner ces actions du
gouvernement pour verdir notre notre
industrie alors le verdissement et la
souveraineté industrielle c'est aussi
parfois intervenir en soutien de nos
grandes entreprises dans le secteur des
déchets vous avez constaté que il y a
quelques mois nous sommes intervenus en
soutien de Suez dont nous avons pris 20%
du capital et puis je voudrais dire un
mot des souverainetés numériques car
beaucoup pas été fait pour installer le
très haut débit sur nos territoires et
nous l'avons financé mais le numérique
ce n'est pas seulement ça c'est aussi
les satellites nous avons soutenu le
rapprochement de telsat avec le réseau
de satellite oneweb pour avoir une
constellation de satellites qui soit à
des tensions européennes et puis autre
domaine où la souveraineté est classée
ce qu'on appelle le Cloud faute d'un mot
français pour le moment bien accepté et
nous avons lancé une initiative avec la
poste avec
Bouygues Telecom et avec
écosystème afin d'avoir une solution
française de Cloud qui s'appelle num
spot et puis enfin il y a évidemment les
souverainetés financières et nous avons
participé depuis plusieurs années à la
consolidation de l'ancrage européen et
du développement du rhône-ex la grande
place financière européenne
enfin après la transformation écologique
et la souveraineté je dirais un mot du
troisième axe qui est la continuation de
notre action en faveur de l'occasion
territoriale et sociale car pour être
socialement juste la création de
richesse doit être équitablement
répartie sur nos territoires évidemment
équitablement partagé entre nos citoyens
et cette conviction irrigue l'action de
la caisse en réalité depuis 1816 car la
lutte contre les fractures territoriales
et sociale demeure notre ADN alors nous
allons continuer notre engagement auprès
de politique publique et nous sommes à
un des acteurs importants de la phase 2
d'action cœur de ville que j'ai des
incités et nous voulons continuer
ses actions dans le cadre par exemple du
programme France 2030 à destination des
quartiers politiques de la ville et qui
est en train de se construire enfin la
cohésion sociale c'est aussi les grands
défis sanitaires et sociaux de notre
temps et je pense à la prise en charge
du grand âge et à la dépendance
pour mener à bien ses chantiers nous
disposons des moyens nécessaires on
s'accorde nous avons gagné en efficacité
aussi sous l'autorité vigilante de la
commission de surveillance pour
renforcer notre politique
opérationnelle et veiller à mieux
utiliser encore l'argent que les
Français nous confient
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
notre pays vous le savez confronté à des
défis d'ampleur historiques d'abord les
effets du réchauffement climatique et
puis les crises internationales la
fragmentation du monde que nous
constatons la caisse a toujours été au
rendez-vous de ces grands défis pour
financer les transformations pour
financer les mutations pour accompagner
le développement de l'économie française
sur l'ensemble des territoires de la
République et je prends l'engagement
devant vous si vous m'accordez votre
confiance de poursuivre ce mandat avec
toute mon énergie et tout l'engagement
dont je suis capable en m'appuyant sur
les équipes valeuses que j'ai déjà
citées merci de votre attention
merci monsieur le Président tout d'abord
je voudrais m'excuser auprès de vous de
arriver à quelques minutes de retard
mais la régulation aérienne a trouvé
subtile de me faire faire deux tours de
Paris
en plus au dessus des nuages sans rien
voir
ce qui est ce qui m'a valu d'arriver
avec quelques minutes de retard veuillez
ma excuser je voudrais remercier Algérie
de Montgolfier de m'avoir évidemment
supplée
nous allons bien sûr j'aurais quelques
mois à dire sur le sur le sujet vous en
doutez monsieur le Président puisque
j'ai moi-même été membre de cette
commission de surveillance de la Caisse
que c'est un dossier qui m'intéresse
énormément mais dans un premier temps je
vais donner la parole à notre rapporteur
général qui est donc chargé de faire le
rapport sur votre
projet de nomination
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Directeur Général mes chers collègues
moi je m'associerai d'abord au vœux de
bonheures années que j'adresse à chacune
et à chacun d'entre nous je pense qu'on
va pas manquer de travail mais pourvu
que on puisse le faire notamment en
étant les uns les autres en bonne santé
pour le reste je pense que une fois
qu'on aura cet état de santé
satisfaisant on pourra donner les uns
les autres le meilleur de nous-mêmes
effectivement rapporteur je vais à la
fois être un peu le poêle à gratter
monsieur directeur général ne m'en
veuillez pas et vous interrogez en
direction de
quelques sujets de d'intérêt qui me
semble être devant nous au regard de du
rôle de la Caisse des dépôts dont j'ai
bien compris que vous étiez prêt à
donner pour une période nouvelle avec un
plat d'énergie renouvelé à défaut d'être
renouvelable alors 5 années
pour tirer finalement passé pour tirer
un bilan de votre action et vous l'avez
balayé à grand trait et je vous en
remercie pour un nouveau mandat si j'ai
bien compris mais ça c'est
la comment dirais-je la singularité
calendaire qui devrait vous amener sur
un mandat de 4 ans
puisque le président de la République
c'est peut-être essayer j'en sais rien
c'est une c'est plutôt un clin d'oeil
pris en compte l'éphéméride le
calendrier pour
pouvoir prolonger votre mandat mais
comme je crois savoir qu'il y a une
limite d'âge et n'y voyait aucune malice
c'est la raison pour laquelle il me
semble que depuis le 8 février vous
pourriez partir pour une période de 4
ans supplémentaires
s'agissant de votre bilan et au-delà ou
peut-être dans le droit fil de ce que
vous avez évoqué moi je voudrais aller
un peu au-delà et peut-être regarder en
direction de deux sujets ce que je vais
appeler la police la politique salariale
et managériale de la caisse et puis le
modèle économique de la banque des
territoires puisqu'elle existe depuis
2018 dans son nouveau modèle
sur la question de finalement de la
politique managériale et salariale de la
Caisse des dépôts des observations des
rapports en rapport notamment de la Cour
des comptes à
évoqué un certain nombre de sujets
parfois même
d'irrégalet d'irrégularité on parle
beaucoup aujourd'hui
comment dirais-je
des sujets de
l'intéressement et donc je voudrais
savoir un peu
où vous en êtes et en tous les cas
quelle mesure ont été mises en œuvre
sous votre autorité pour faire en sorte
que les cette politique d'intéressement
et on dit aujourd'hui de partage de la
valeur soit peut-être plus justement
répartie et dans des proportions
vues par des parlementaires plus
conformes aux attendus de la situation
actuelle
quelles sont les
orientations les décisions que vous avez
été amenés à prendre dans ce dans cette
direction et puis je voudrais également
évoquer je dirais l'avenir enfin à la
fois le bilan sur la création depuis
moins de 5 ans de la banque des
territoires puisque effectivement et
vous l'avez dit je crois qu'on le
perçoit les uns les autres
un certain nombre de territoires et j'y
reviendrai un tout petit peu à la fin
non pas accès parce que parce qu'ils non
seulement il manque d'ingénierie mais il
manque de moyens tout simplement et je
mets ça en relation avec ce qu'on va
appeler le sentiment de desclassement
les fractures territoriales qui sont qui
existent de fait entre les territoires
les mieux dotés les mieux équipés les
plus attractifs les plus riches et les
plus puissants et puis ceux qui n'ont
pas fonctionné à la même vitesse voire
même puisque je vous ai entendu être
très attaché je le crois à l'industrie
des territoires qui ont subi la vague de
désindustrialisation sans trouver de
capacité de rebondir donc
comment vouliez vous les choses parce
que une des difficultés c'est que dans
ces territoires souvent dans
l'accompagnement les frais et coups
supportés par les collectivités voir les
contraintes qui pèsent sur elles ne leur
facilite pas les choses
envisagez-vous de remédier à ces
difficultés
sur le le la question d'ailleurs
du modèle de la banque des territoires
un rapport récent de la Cour des comptes
explique finalement en tous les cas
points du doigt la fragilisation par
la Cour le dit elle-même à trop faible
examen de la valeur créée par les
investissements parfois d'ailleurs par
des risques de chevauchement entre la
caisse BPI France et la poste j'ai
entendu vos propos vous expliquer que
ça fonctionne bien ça fonctionne
peut-être mieux qu'avant mais
manifestement je ne suis pas sûr qu'on
soit encore arrivé mais le je dirais la
création est encore récente donc ça
s'entend et puis parfois par un niveau
de marge insuffisant du fond d'épargne
pour couvrir les frais de gestion donc
peut-être
pouvez-vous
enfin je vous propose de répondre à ces
interrogations pour voir si dans le
droit fil de ce que vous avez exposé il
y a des inflexions ou si vous pensez que
la situation sont aujourd'hui solidement
établies et finalement qu'il n'y a plus
beaucoup de marge de de progrès et puis
je voudrais évoquer un peu l'avenir de
l'accueil des dépôts vous nous en avez
tracé un certain nombre
d'enjeux que je partage je partage
effectivement le c'est plus un modèle de
transformation de de notre de nos
sociétés donc y compris de la nôtre qui
est devant nous plutôt qu'un modèle de
transition mais la transformation je
l'évoquais il y a quelques instants
elle me paraît de voir prendre en compte
ce phénomène de fracture et de
fragmentation
qui ne manquent pas de m'inquiéter
puisque vous avez évoqué les transports
les préoccupations et l'accompagnement
évidemment différents lorsque vous devez
organiser un transport massif dans des
espaces urbains et où métropolitain et
quand dans le même temps il est besoin
de construire des solutions nouvelles
répondant à des enjeux d'accessibilité
au travail ou au centre urbain pour des
territoires qui quel que soit les
compétences n'ont pas les moyens non
plus les moyens financiers et non pas
n'existe pas de bons moyens
je dirais technique pour permettre une
offre de transport
performante parce que je crois que c'est
peut-être ce sera ma dernière question
comment voulez-vous
le rôle de la de la Caisse des dépôts de
la banque des territoires
pour finalement permettre à notre pays à
nos territoires dans leur dévastés de
concilier ce double enjeu finalement de
performance et de cohésion quand je
parle performant évidemment pour moi
c'est de la performance économique et
écologique je crois qu'il faut lier les
deux si on ne les lit pas il arrivera à
ce qu'on voit en ce moment c'est-à-dire
des dérives que je qualifierais
d'excessives et de populistes autour de
l'écologie et sa nuit à la cause
écologique et de cohésion c'est une
cohésion sociale vous avez notamment
parlé du logement je crois que c'est un
facteur important pour pas dire le
facteur prioritaire sur lequel on doit
se battre mais c'est une cohésion
sociale et territoriale et dans ces deux
enjeux la caisse peut avoir un dépôt à
un apport important avec
avec un risque je le dis c'est le risque
du coup où découpe que vous faites
supporter et qui sont vous savez parfois
peut-être aussi parce que vous êtes
l'acteur majeur prioritaire parfois le
seul mais qui est un coup qui pèse lourd
dans les finances des acteurs que sont
les collectivités et je pense quand je
dis ça notamment aux collectivités qui
sont à dominantes rurales
merci monsieur le rapporteur général je
vous demande monsieur le Président de
bien vouloir répondre en premier
reportage en général en quelques en
quelques minutes sachant que nous avons
ensuite quasiment l'ensemble de nos
collègues qui souhaitent s'exprimer
cette sur la l'action de la caisse nous
avons des demandes de nombreuses et
c'est et c'est bien et c'est bien c'est
bien naturel je voudrais pour ma part
juste peut-être
d'abord effectivement faire par cette
expérience de la commission de
surveillance à vos côtés et vous dire
que cette expérience s'est menée à un
moment très particulier puisque on avait
un changement de volume de la caisse de
manière majeure vous l'avez rappelé
quelques poils la graisse d'un manque
des territoires
qui est quelque chose qui a vraiment
modifié structurellement par rapport aux
élus locaux notamment la vision de la
caisse par par les par les îles locaux
l'entrée de la pose de la suite vous
l'avez dit autant de autant de majeurs
qui ont fait changer totalement ce
qu'est la Caisse des Dépôts aujourd'hui
et puis peut-être vous dire d'ailleurs
que bon quand je suis rentré vous savez
l'expression qui était toujours la même
expression c'était la vieille dame
vieille dame bon aujourd'hui c'est pas
une vieille dame c'est c'est pas un
jeune sautillant mais enfin comment dire
l'expression vieillissam je vois pas
comment on peut la formuler aujourd'hui
je crois que la totalement a disparu je
suis même pas pourquoi j'en parle sauf
pour
sauf pour considérer que c'est une
expression qui est derrière nous et qui
montre bien l'évolution dans ces
quelques dernières années je voudrais
moi poser une question complémentaire
peut-être celle du rapporteur je crois
qu'il avait ça un peu dans l'esprit
il a évoqué les questions quelquefois de
lecture entre ce que fait la caisse ce
que fait la BPI est-ce que fait
éventuellement la pose sur les les
risques de chevauchement éventuels la
question vous a été posée moi je
parlerai plutôt de finalement c'est une
organisation qui aujourd'hui presque ou
ou il y a eu il y a un foisonnement des
initiatives et d'ailleurs dans votre
propos introductif vous y avez presque
fait référence vous avez lister cet
homme de d'opérations qui vous
paraissent importantes mais il y en a
encore beaucoup plus que cela en réalité
donc il y a un foisonnement ce qui veut
dire une capacité d'initiative sur le
terrain par les agents de la caisse par
les personnels de la caisse qui
proposent des des solutions qui
n'attendent pas uniquement des de
répondre à des demandes à des
sollicitations de l'État les choses là
aussi ont bien changé mais si je peux me
permettre comment ensuite sur un système
aussi foisonnant et aussi large comment
contrôle-t-on finalement l'ensemble de
ces projets
pour parler de contrôle interne contrôle
externe comment comment une telle
machine ce regard se contrôle du point
de vue à la fois de son efficacité de
son utilité sociale tout simplement et
national et à la fois en termes de
d'efficacité économique bien entendu
donc voilà complémentairement en
rapporteur général si je puis dire en
quelques minutes si vous pouvez en 10
minutes peut-être répondre aux
rapporteur général sur ces premières
questions puis nous ouvrirons le débat
et les questions de nos collègues
bien merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le rapporteur général
ça commence effectivement par des
questions ambitieuses peut-être le
président ce que je commencerai par à
parler votre si un porteur général le
permet quand vous parlez de
chevauchement en fait les mandats des
institutions financières du groupe sont
claires et de même qu'il existe dans
l'organisation judiciaire française un
tribunal des conflits nous avons une
sorte de tribunal d'y conflits qui tous
les trois mois réunis autour de votre
serviteur les dirigeants des
institutions financières du groupe BPI
France on y inclut CNP ce fil la Banque
Postale la banque des territoires avec
évidemment Philippe Val en tant que
patron du groupe La Poste de façon
précisément à veiller ce qu'il n'y ait
pas de querelles de frontières et est-ce
que les rôles soient bien établi et ça
ça fonctionne bien et d'ailleurs je
dirais que les incidents de frontières
qui ne nous remontent plus parce que je
pense qu'il y en a plus alors en
revanche vous avez raison
ce président est vous l'avez vécu euh
quand vous étiez membre de la commission
de surveillance il y a un foisonnement
d'initiative parce que moi je pense
qu'on peut aussi être entrepreneur
public d'ailleurs la plupart des élus
sont des entrepreneurs publics à voir ce
qui se passe sur nos territoires et nous
jouons ce rôle alors effectivement après
il faut que ce soit bien encadré alors
c'est encadré par de nombreuses règles
et de nombreuses doctrines en réalité
peut-être même trop
d'abord
nous avons nos règles éthiques qui sont
évidemment très importantes nous avons
une discipline financière très stricte
et ça c'est une tradition mais nous y
veillons et puis on a été nous avons une
organisation et j'ai beaucoup travaillé
sur notre organisation il y a 5 ans de
façon à ce que chaque équipe est un
mandat précis et donc qui dit mandat dit
suivi et donc nous suivons moi après moi
l'évolution des engagements des
investissements et nous vérifions que
tout ça se fait de façon rentable
pas trop rentable d'ailleurs parce que
la valeur doit revenir au territoire
autant qu'à la caisse au moins et puis
comme nous sommes depuis la loi pacte
supervisée par la CPR nous avons une
armature de contrôle qui est en réalité
extrêmement dense le contrôle interne le
premier niveau deuxième niveau le
contrôle périodique c'est ce que fait
l'audit et puis il est contrôle
naturellement de la Cour des comptes et
d'autres organismes donc moi je pense
que ce foisonnement il est favorable au
développement de nos territoires de vos
territoires devrais-je dire dès lors
qu'il est il est encadré
et ce qui veut dire que de temps en
temps et c'est aussi le rôle d'un
entrepreneur que il faut couper de
l'initiative qui ne fonctionnerait pas
mais c'est vrai que moi je vois plutôt
de la richesse alors pour en revenir aux
questions de Jean-François Husson sur la
politique salariale vous faites bien
monsieur le rapporteur général de
rappeler que il y a à peu près 5 ans
d'ailleurs la Cour des comptes avait
émis quelques recommandations
voilà c'est assez sévère elles ont
toutes été mises en oeuvre et nous avons
beaucoup renforcé nos politiques
salariales pour que elle soit
conforme naturellement totalement au
texte alors sur sur la question de
l'intéressement c'est vrai que en tant
que établissement ayant une rentabilité
d'ailleurs honorable il y a un accord
d'intéressement cet accord
d'intéressement il porte sur 8% de la
masse salariale je rappelle que les
textes nous permettent d'aller jusqu'à
20% donc c'est plutôt moins mais c'est
même éloigné du maximum et cet accord
d'intéressement il fonctionne chaque
année naturellement c'est une
négociation avec les partenaires sociaux
mais de façon à ce qu'il améliore
l'équité des rémunérations c'est à dire
que pour l'essentiel les sommes versées
sont les mêmes qu'on est des salaires
modestes ou plus élevés c'est-à-dire
donc en proportion ça profite plus aux
petits salaires au salaire plus élevé ce
qui correspond à une politique sociale
que moi-même je souhaite très fort parce
que elle me paraît plus juste d'ailleurs
à cet égard je rappelle que c'est pas
tout à fait votre question monsieur
rapporteur général mais nous avons
utilisé la même façon la prime pouvoir
d'achat en versant des montants plus
élevés au titre de la prime pouvoir
d'achat au petit salaire et en fait on
envers son pas du tout au salaire élevé
et naturellement pas du tout au cadre
dirigeant
j'en profite pour dire que notre
politique salariale naturellement
vise à la fois à maintenir un parcours
de carrière motivant pour l'ensemble de
nos agents et de nos salariés puisque
nous avons des agents publics et des
salariés de de droit privé mais avec une
attention particulière pour pour les
salaires les moins élevés alors si si
j'en viens à la question que vous posez
sur la banque des territoires
je ne prétendrai pas que nous sommes au
bout du chemin et nous avons beaucoup de
simplification à opérer
alors d'abord nous nous les opérons
parce que la banque des territoires
c'est aussi une plateforme digitale et
le site de la banque des territoires
permet aux élus d'avoir accès à beaucoup
d'informations beaucoup d'informations
ouvertes qui sont organisées leur
permettant de suivre dans leur vie
l'évolution du commerce l'évolution des
consommations
j'en ai parlé et tout ça et
effectivement plus simple j'ai voulu
aussi simplifier les procédures beaucoup
de procédures de de près sont accordés
de façon digitalisée et donc de façon
plus plus simple mais la simplification
et là je partage tout à fait votre point
reste pour nous un enjeu quotidien parce
que je sais pas si c'est français si
c'est lié aux institutions publiques ou
si c'est général mais c'est vrai que
nous avons un monde qui tente à générer
de la complication et notre rôle à nous
dirigeant me semble-t-il et de le
réduire alors sur la valeur des
investissements tels que vu par par la
Cour des comptes moi je me permets de
contester ce point avec respect d'abord
parce que
j'ai souhaité que le coût du capital de
la banque des territoires soit beaucoup
plus faible que celui d'un acteur privé
nous sommes un acteur public la valeur
doit aller au territoire et donc quand
parfois on propose un projet qui est
trop rentable je dis qu'il y a un
problème que ce projet soit peut être
traité par le privé soit peut-être que
l'équilibre entre ce qui revient tout
territoire et ce qui revient à
l'investisseur n'est pas le bon
deuxièmement nous devons prendre des
risques nous devons prendre des risques
que les acteurs privés ne prennent pas
et parfois ces risques se matérialise
par des pertes ce qui est logique de ce
côté là d'ailleurs en réalité il y en a
fort peu au contraire quand nous avons
pris par exemple le risque d'installer
le très haut débit dans des territoires
ruraux aujourd'hui ces raisons une
valeur très considérable et donc en
réalité et la banque des territoires par
rapport à ce qui se faisait avant fait
plus tourner son portefeuille voir plus
d'actifs qui ont été ainsi créés et
souvent ces sessions se font avec des
plus-values élevées qui permettent de
valider les options qui qui ont été
prises
puis vous avez évoqué c'est un point de
monde différent et vous le savez le taux
de marge des fonds départs donc ça c'est
un autre bilan que nous gérons pour le
compte de l'État donc c'est l'épargne
populaire que nous prêtons
il y a un équilibre d'ensemble
l'ensemble des fonds d'épargne
aujourd'hui enfin la fin de l'année 2022
c'est 350 milliards d'euros
3030 milliards d'euros de ressources
venant du livret A du ldds du Livret
d'Épargne Populaire et puis 20 milliards
d'euros de fonds propres qui sont
évidemment intégralement investis pour
190 milliards d'euros dans le logement
social et dans l'action territoriale et
pour le reste dans l'économie française
nous veillons à ce que l'équilibre soit
maintenu en complicité avec la direction
générale du Trésor qui qui a tué de ce
bilan alors vous avez raison monsieur le
sénateur c'est vrai que la hausse des
taux est notamment la hausse du taux du
livret A mais sous tension ce bilan mais
par ailleurs il y a une protection qui
est donnée à l'actif pardon d'être un
peu technique mais je suis dans la
commission des finances du Sénat il y a
un portefeuille de 50 milliards d'euros
d'obligations indexées sur l'inflation
européenne qui cette année va vraiment
couvrir ses frais et puis la plupart des
prêts basés sur le livret A en fait sont
indexés puisque l'emprunteur logement
social n'a que laïcité paye le taux du
livret A plus une marge mais vous avez
raison c'est un point d'attention un
moment où les taux remonte et nous y
prêtons attention enfin la question des
fractures territoriales et notamment des
petites collectivités alors de
commentaires à cet égard
je suis extrêmement sensible à cette
question et donc depuis l'origine nous
avons demandé à nos directions
régionales d'avoir des objectifs non pas
en volume d'opération mais en nombre
d'opérations pour s'assurer que ça
bénéficiait à plus de collectivités et
d'ailleurs dans la période il y a plus
de 1500 communes nouvelles qui
auparavant de travailler pas que la
banque des territoires et qui m'en
entraîne avec nous parce que nous sommes
attentifs à ce que des communes de plus
petites tailles et accès aux services
naturellement de la banque des
territoires mais j'irai plus loin vous
avez tout à fait raison vous connaissez
dans votre territoire c'est ces sujets
mieux que beaucoup d'autres
la question c'est que les communes de
petite taille les communes rurales n'ont
pas les services des grandes communes
des métropoles
et c'est exactement pour ça que le
projet petite ville de demain dont j'ai
parlé veille à mettre à disposition des
communes rurales de l'ingénierie qui est
intégralement financé par la Caisse des
Dépôts je veux dire que nous mettons sur
ce projet petite ville de demain 200
millions d'euros de subventions à
l'ingénierie qui est une somme
considérable pour nous c'est deux fois
plus que ce que nous avons fait pour
action cœur de ville nous avons mis 100
millions d'euros d'ingénierie et grâce à
cela conjointement avec les villes
concernées nous finançons de
l'ingénierie et je peux vous dire que ce
programme démarre en flèche maintenant
c'est
spécialiste ont été recrutés sont en
place et vont accompagner ces communes
rurales dans leur développement et donc
ça c'est une simplification parce que ça
permet d'avoir des spécialistes des
femmes et des hommes qui vont
accompagner cette transformation alors
ça marche dans tous les domaines
juste deux exemples en matière de très
haut débit un des moments heureux il y
en a beaucoup dans la vie d'un directeur
général de la Caisse des dépôts de ce de
mon précédent mandat c'était quand
j'étais à consolation maisonnette
au cœur d'une vallée du Doux magnifique
département français au fond d'une
vallée pour installer le Très Haut Débit
auprès d'une abbaye et d'un petit centre
où il y avait 32 personnes qui vivaient
voilà et ça la France permet cela et
franchement je pense qu'il y a peu de
pays du monde où ça se passe et puis
vous parlez à juste titre des transports
publics dans les zones rurales ou dans
les zones épars je donnais un exemple
dans le Nord la ville de Fourmies ou des
initiatives originales ont été prises
pour mettre à disposition des habitants
des voitures des bus c'est tout un tas
de systèmes vous savez que on peut pas
concurrencer les taxis donc ça peut pas
être un service d'héritablement à la
demande mais il y a un garage collectif
dans le centre de fourmis qui met à
disposition des habitants de la ville
des scooters des véhicules prêtés à la
journée ou des bus et donc il y a un
foisonnement d'initiative que évidemment
nous nous accompagnons voilà le
président m'ayant donné 10 minutes je
veux pas déborder mais voilà notre pays
de ce côté-là est incroyablement vivace
et et plein d'idées
merci Monsieur prison de pas avoir
débordé d'ailleurs vous verrez que nos
collègues ne vont pas déborder non plus
Hervé Moret pour deux minutes
merci monsieur le Président j'aurais
aimé vous interroger Monsieur le
Directeur général sur un certain nombre
de sujets mais comme on est dans le
cadre de d'une audition article 13 je
vais revenir quand même sur les
questions relatives ou personnelles
parce que dans votre réponse au
rapporteur général vous avez fait
référence à un rapport d'il y a 5 ans
mais je crois que pas plus tard qu'en
2022 il y a eu un référé de la Cour des
comptes qui soulignait que si des
progrès avaient été améliorés il y avait
encore des progrès à accomplir et
notamment par rapport à l'augmentation
de la masse salariale qui augmente en
moyenne de 3% à la Caisse des Dépôts
15,9% 14,9% exactement en 5 ans et sur
vous l'avez évoqué la politique
d'intéressement qui en fait ne répond
pas vraiment à l'objectif puisque tout
le monde dit tout le monde accède à
cette intéressement et parce que les
objectifs fixés sont très bas et vous
avez vous-même dit qu'en fait c'était
plus une prime qu'un intéressement donc
je voudrais savoir si vous souhaitez ou
si vous comptez donner suite à ces
que de la Cour des comptes ou si vous
considérez que tout est réglé et dernier
point sur la banque des territoires la
Cour des comptes a été aussi un peu plus
sévère que que vous-même mais c'est
normal en disant je cite que la place de
la banque des territoires reste marginal
à part dans le domaine du logement
social pour les collectivités locales
donc comment faire pour que les choses
évoluent positivement j'ai tenu dans le
temps sur le président parfait parfait
exemplaire
merci Hervé
si monsieur le Président la Caisse des
dépôts est un acteur important du
développement territorial sous
différentes facettes cela a été dit tout
à l'heure et pour ce qui concerne la
Bretagne je constate qu'effectivement
elle est particulièrement visible ce qui
me réjouit effectivement alors dans
votre propre éliminaire Monsieur le
Directeur Général
vous avez évoqué l'importance des
énergies renouvelables notamment dans
les dimensions solaires et éoliennes et
puis vous avez également évoqué la
question de la réindustrialisation de la
France qui est effectivement une
préoccupation que nous partageons je
voudrais appeler votre attention sur la
nécessité pour ce qui concerne les
énergies renouvelables sans doute de
porter une attention particulière à
d'autres formes de production que celles
qui sont déjà soutenues notamment pour
ce qui concerne le domaine maritime par
exemple l'énergie hydrolienne ou
soutenir d'autres types de production
qui peuvent essaimer dans notre pays qui
sont de nature peut-être demain à
apporter aussi un complément d'activité
industrielle sur les territoire ça me
semble important que la Caisse des
dépôts qui est un acteur important du
développement territorial soit
particulièrement investi sur ces sujets
merci Michel Antoine Lefèvre puis Pascal
ça vole des lits oui merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Directeur Général
chouette profiter de votre audition de
votre commission devant notre commission
pour vous interroger sur la situation de
la Caisse des Dépôts notamment dans le
sa relation avec les bailleurs sociaux
suite au relèvement du taux du livret A
vous avez évoqué ce sujet alors
l'argumentaire de la Caisse des Dépôts
actuellement c'est de leur dire à ses
bailleurs tenez bon ça ira mieux dans
d'ici deux ans alors c'est vrai que la
caisse va devoir décaisser plus fort et
présenter des comptes d'épargne négatifs
mais du coup j'allais dire
l'autofinancement des bailleurs sociaux
va complètement s'effondrer
alors même que la Caisse des Dépôts leur
apporte des aides à des taux plus élevés
du fait donc de l'indexation sur le
livret A c'est vrai que du coup les
bailleurs sociaux semblent être dans une
impasse
persuadé que justement les choses vont
s'améliorer d'ici 2 ans à titre
d'illustration l'incidence de ces
housses dans le l'Office que j'ai la
chance de présider dans mon département
de l'Aisne
aux du livret A de 2022 et celle de 2023
ça représente 3 millions d'euros et
encore je précise que cette office c'est
un endettement
raisonnable à 27% et l'effet va être
dévastateur sur un certain nombre
d'office qui sont particulièrement
endettés alors pourquoi ne pas proposer
plutôt au bailleur de différé le
remboursement parce qu'on apporterait la
davantage de solutions et puis surtout
on permettrait
véritablement un autofinancement plus
important qui permettra justement aussi
la poursuite des investissements vous
avez évoqué vous même et j'y souscrit la
transformation écologique si on veut
justement rénover faire la rénovation
thermique il faudra aussi que nos
offices et une certaine un certain
autofinancement pour pour régler tout ça
et puis enfin pour conclure je veux
souligner que il y a des dispositifs
effectivement intéressants vous les avez
mentionnés les échos prêts et puis ce
que j'ai pas tout à fait moi je l'avais
appelé les aides en termes de deuxième
vie pour redonner vie effectivement à un
certain nombre d'anciens HLM et c'est
plutôt
judicieux on a de très bons résultats
mais j'ai l'air je vous alerte là-dessus
sur notamment par rapport à la situation
dans les territoires détendus merci
merci Antoine parce que ça vole d'élite
puis Eric Bocquet
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
Lombard je pourrais dire presque chers
collègue si vous avez été conseiller
municipal à Fontenay et que la Caisse
des Dépôts a failli arriver à Ivry mais
vous avez choisi de rester à Paris
donc je vais prendre un sujet Monsieur
le Directeur Général pour vous dire que
puisqu'on est la reconduction d'une
nomination sur la base d'un bilan qui
est très dense c'est la poste
parce que la poche vous avez interpellé
et je vous avais parlé des fermetures de
postes des bureaux dans mon département
d'ailleurs ce qu'on fait beaucoup de mes
collègues de toute sensibilité et là
vous m'aviez expliqué évidemment là les
problèmes de l'effondrement avec le
covid l'activité déficitaire voilà et
puis moi je m'étais dit bon il y avait
peut-être y avoir un redressement moi il
y avait un loup dans votre réponse à
l'époque en 2022 c'était déjà la
disparition du timbre rouge c'était
prévu c'était envisagé
et le timbre vert a vu son délai allongé
deux à trois jours il est commercialisé
depuis le 1er octobre 2011 il est devenu
le timbre systématiquement proposé
et c'est pourquoi je vous dis ça parce
que c'est un petit aide d'une anecdote
peut-être mais c'est le seul timbre à
même de pallier aux réduction de
personnel à la baisse du nombre de
centres de tri à la diminution des
tournées donc là on a on a un
affaiblissement du service public de
proximité donc je vous entends sur
cohésion sociale et territoires mais là
je vous dis ça fait pas la maille
[Musique]
mais vous allez vers un glissement
d'être totalement l'acteur privé
comment vous m'expliquez que vous avez
investi dans des secteurs concurrentiels
vous avez investi dans l'entreprise
Transdev qui se trouve en concurrence
avec des acteurs publics Keolis les RATP
la SNCF est-ce que c'est ça le rôle de
la Caisse des Dépôts est-ce que c'est le
rôle de la Caisse des Dépôts comme
acteurs publics j'ai même vu vous avez
vu mais vous le savez mes collègues
aussi vous avez pris un risque pas
énorme au plan financier vous avez
racheté Stuart la startup qui ubérise la
livraison express urbaine et qui
précarise les jeunes donc ce que je vais
vous dire voyez il y a un choix
politique qui est celui de transformer
une transfation une transformation
radicale de l'entreprise La Poste on la
changeant de modèle je pense que c'est
pas une orientation que je peux
souscrire donc voilà de par ces deux
éléments très rapides parce que le ça
demanderait beaucoup plus de temps
Monsieur le Directeur Général d'avoir un
exercice critique constructif voilà de
par les choix de changement de modèle de
la poste et d'une évolution d'une
doctrine qui n'est pas celle à l'origine
de la Caisse des Dépôts
je vais pas vous taquiner mais vous
rappelez peut-être un de vos anciens
anciens qui disaient que la Caisse des
Dépôts c'est une banque socialiste dans
une économie capitaliste là j'ai bien
l'impression que la Caisse des Dépôts
était bien une banque capitaliste dans
un système capitaliste tout à fait
respectable aussi mais néanmoins c'est
comme ça donc vous comprendrez et par
correction je voulais vous le dire et
non pas le faire de manière clandestine
moi pour ces conditions là qui sont des
éléments stratégiques qui ne sont pas
des éléments personnels vraiment je ne
participerai pas au vote voilà merci
merci parce que à Éric Bocquet bien
merci monsieur le Président pour
préparer cette audition je me suis
replongé dans quelques articles
notamment un article des échos du 26
avril 2022 que je vais me permettre de
citer et vous avez écrit monsieur
Lombard je crois que c'est dans votre
livre au cœur de la finance utile une
petite magnifique
il finit le libéralisme profite toujours
aux puissants
vous dites un peu plus loin on a le
droit au manager une part excessive de
la richesse crée les actionnaires ont
repris le pouvoir qu'ils avaient perdu
après la Seconde Guerre mondiale le
capital a acheté le management à coup de
bonus ne rien changer c'est prendre le
risque politique d'une révolution
sociale vous comprenez que ces termes
font chaud à nos oreilles est tellement
vrai et dans le prolongement il y en
écho de ses propos je citerai également
le monsieur Éric Monet qui fut le
lauréat du prix du meilleur jeune
économiste l'an dernier il disait propos
de la caisse il est important que la
Caisse des dépôts et BPI France soit
utilisé pleinement pour protéger
l'épargne populaire financer le long
terme le développement régional vous
l'avez évoqué et ne deviennent pas des
gestionnaires d'actifs prenants modèles
sur les acteurs privés cela peut se
faire par un retour à un modèle qui a
porté ses fruits en France en associant
les parlementaires les syndicats et le
patronat dans les conseils
d'administration de ces institutions et
vous savez de ce point de vue la
gouvernance a évolué sensiblement alors
on a quelques interrogations bon ces
affirmations ne nous intéressent et on y
adhère complètement mais je vais citer
également l'un de vos collègues Monsieur
Laurent gilberberg qui est directeur des
relations institutionnelles européennes
et internationales à la caisse qui dit
les domaines investissement du livret A
pourraient être très large il faut
reconnaître la capacité des
investisseurs publics à des risquer les
investissements et à aimanter les autres
investisseurs fin de citation donc vous
comprendrez que c'est déclarations
suscitent de chez nous des
interrogations où est la ligne de la
Caisse des Dépôts quelle est la
philosophie quel est le la feuille de
route la Caisse des Dépôts c'est un
résultat net agrégé qui dépasse
aujourd'hui les quatre milliards on sait
qu'on vit dans une économie largement et
de plus en plus financiarisé tout ça se
finit ça arrive à vitesse grand V donc
tous les questions que qu'on a souhaité
vous soumettre parce qu'elles sont
évoqué moi pour ma part j'en aurai trois
trois petites questions quels sont les
leviers dont dispose la Caisse des
dépôts pour accroître la construction
des logements sociaux dont on connaît la
crise aujourd'hui qui n'est pas nouvelle
plus fondamentalement est-ce que vous
reprenez l'engagement aujourd'hui que
chaque euro de fondé par l'épargne nos
concitoyens est concitoyenne servira
effectivement à financer le logement
social et la politique de la ville et
enfin à propos du niveau du nouveau
livret vert avec une critique forte
d'ailleurs de la part de notre ministre
Bruno Le Maire du Livret Développement
durable et solidaire pourrait-il
échapper au fond d'épargne et ainsi
réduire la collecte du fond d'épargne
pour financer pour finalement me lancer
le financement du logement social voilà
merci merci
Eric Vincent évely puis Vanina paoliga
c'est avec vous que nous avons le
plaisir d'ouvrir notre séquence de
travail
2023 permettez-moi de vous présenter mes
vœux ainsi que l'ensemble de mes
collègues je reviendrai pour ma part sur
une question déjà évoquée mais nous
étions pas concertés par Antoine
Lefebvre mais il me paraît pas inutile
de le faire à nouveau de façon à ce que
vous puissiez mesurer que cette
préoccupation traverse notre commission
au delà des sensibilités politiques
c'est la question j'irai du crédit que
la Caisse des Dépôts accorde au
mouvement locatif social et en
particulier la question de l'indexation
de beaucoup de ces prêts sur la base de
la rémunération du Livret A qui enchait
très fortement le coût de ses emprunts
pour de nombreux organismes HLM et qui
va à mon câblement conduire ceci à en
raison de la reste leur autofinancement
à réduire leur programme
d'investissement qu'il s'agisse de
réalisation de travaux neufs et diocèse
si c'est important d'autres collègues
ont évoqué la question du financement de
la construction
locative social mais aussi bien sûr les
programmes de rénovation qui sont
parfois très coûteux et qui se financent
largement par l'empreinte donc
préoccupation je sais pour l'avoir
évoqué avec
des dirigeants de société HLM que
ils avaient il y a quelques années
sollicités
la possibilité d'obtenir des
financements
taux fixes alors que les taux étaient
très bas on leur a répondu du côté de la
caisse que ça n'était pas
souhaitable et que les choses iraient
bien qu'il y aurait une vigilance
particulière d'apporter je dirais à se
financement
et que si d'aventure ce qui ne manque
pas de se produire bien entendu les taux
venait à remonter et bien on pourrait
examiner cette question aujourd'hui il
se trouve totalement étranglé pour
certains d'entre eux Antoine Lefebvre
évoqué l'organisme dont il a sur la
présidence dans l'Aisne mais il y a
d'autres exemples bien entendu et donc
c'est une préoccupation extrêmement
lourde sur laquelle on aimerait entendre
à propos rassurant de votre part pas
simplement à propos général mais à
propos de circonstancié qui nous disent
comment dans quel délai et selon quel
modalité cette question pourrait être
traitée parce que les centrales merci
merci Vincent Vanina pas Eugen puis
Georges patient oui monsieur le
Président mes chers collègues tout
d'abord une bonne année de santé et de
paix à chacun d'entre vous pour 2023
Monsieur le Directeur Général merci pour
cette présentation programmatique j'ai
trois petites questions en mode des
zooms qui vont passer du maquereau au
micro avec deux impératifs me
semble-t-il pour accélérer les
transitions le temps l'argent c'est une
combinatoire sur laquelle on n'est pas
très très fort dans notre pays et par
laquelle souvent on pêche je pense
premier sujet la biodiversité
pensez-vous qu'ils sont envisageable que
le fond biodiversité de la caisse
travail étroitement avec les communes
forestières de France qui sont souvent
en zone rurale et puissent leur apporter
des soutiens financiers elles sont
confrontées à beaucoup de problématiques
liées au changement climatique aux
crises sanitaires etc est-ce qu'on peut
travailler en ce sens sur l'industrie
verte je partage l'ambition les les
communications qui ont été faites par
notre ministre de l'économie et des
finances en revanche quand je regarde ça
sous l'angle concret qu'est-ce que je
constate c'est que le Canada les
États-Unis font très très fort
pour attirer nos startups à vocation
industrielles leur construire des usines
dont ils assurent 80% de la charge
financière de l'investissement en leur
trouvant des fonciers des risqués etc et
que quand bien même on réussirait à
faire la même chose en Europe on a quand
même un gros caillou dans la chaussure
qui est notre incapacité à avoir des
procédures
moins chers et diligentes
le Canada les États-Unis ont des
procédures fastraques pour
l'homologation de tous les nouveaux
produits industriels verts etc qu'on n'a
pas nous on a des délais qui sont de 24
mois 36 mois au bas mot et donc en fait
si on ne travaille pas sur ces deux
ressorts je crains que il soit déjà trop
tard en fait
je redescends au niveau communal et
effectivement l'ingénierie est très
décisive en fait pour les mères qui sont
tous porteurs de projet même dans les
plus petites communes qui soient en
revanche ce que je constate c'est que là
encore il y a un problème de
d'homothétie entre la ressource ingénie
et les temps de conventionnement
financiers entre les différents échelons
de collectivités la Région le
Département etc ce temps souvent excède
la durée de la mandature d'une équipe
municipale ça fait que les devis qu'on a
soumis
quatre ans avant ils sont obsolètes
qu'il faut réactualiser les coûts etc
etc donc est-ce qu'on peut aussi
améliorer les process de ce chef-là
pensez-vous merci beaucoup merci Vanina
Georges patiente puis Thierry Cosic
Monsieur le Directeur Général
je voudrais souligner la très bonne
progression des activités de la caisse
dans les outre-mer ces derniers années
sous votre mandat notamment par
l'intermédiaire de la CDC de CDC habitat
et de la banque des territoires bon
simplement n'est-il pas venu le temps
d'instaurer une direction générale
en Guyane
mon territoire qui qui dépend d'une
Direction Régionale anti Guyane située
en Guadeloupe à plus de 2000 km bon
d'autant plus important quelle est cette
direction régionale que les activités
progressent énormément en Guyane plus
d'ailleurs qu'aux Antilles et que si on
fait une petite comparaison il y a une
direction générale en Corse en Guyane
avec des activités moindres qu'en Guyane
merci Georges Thierry couzik merci
monsieur le Président moi j'ai une
question qui est qui va peut-être être
un peu à contre le courant de l'audition
mais je voudrais je m'interroge en fait
sur un point et je pense que le Sénat
est dans son rôle de contrôle de
l'action du gouvernement sur la question
je vais vous poser et notamment
j'aimerais revenir sur les conditions de
votre nomination et notamment de
l'arrêté du ministre de l'économie qui
est Paris aux JO le 7 décembre dernier
qui vous désigne comme personne chargée
d'intérim au poste de directeur général
de la Caisse des dépôts à compter du 8
décembre 2022 et jusqu'à la nomination
d'un nouveau directeur général je
m'étonne d'un tel arrêté dans la mesure
où à la suite de la réforme de la
gouvernance de la Caisse des dépôts et
des consignations qui a été décidée par
la loi pacte et mise en application par
un décret du 20 novembre 2019
le code monétaire est financier a été
modifié et dispose désormais en son
article
r518-11 quand l'absence ou d'empêchement
du directeur général ou de vacances de
l'emploi son intérim est assuré par le
directeur général délégué désigné à cet
effet par arrêté du mini chargé
d'économie publie au Journal officiel de
la République française
la lecture de cet article je comprends
que votre nomination pourrait ne pas
être conforme au droit puisque seul le
directeur général délégué en fonction
donc en l'occurrence Olivier Sechet
aurait pu en être charger et donc de ce
fait est-ce que vous ne craignez pas que
cette décision du ministre de l'économie
ne fasse naître un problème de sécurité
juridique dans les décisions que vous
avez été amenées à prendre depuis votre
nomination est-ce que vous pouvez nous
éclairer sur ce point merci merci
Thierry Sylvie vermeiller puis Daniel
Bruyer
merci monsieur le Président meilleur vœu
à toutes et tous Monsieur le Directeur
Général vous avez évoqué dans votre
propos liminaire
le rôle de la Caisse des Dépôts et
Consignation dans la gestion des
retraites c'est elle irait également les
mines la Banque de France le RAF etc je
voudrais vous interroger un petit peu
sur le fond de réserve des retraites
avec un encours d'à peu près 26
milliards actuellement
très simplement compte tenu des
performances de gestion de se fond de
réserve des retraites plus de 4% ce qui
est quand même beaucoup je crois 4,6%
depuis 10 ans c'est quand même beaucoup
est-ce qu'il vous semble que ce Fonds de
réserve des retraites
doit réellement être dédié à rembourser
de la dette sociale ou au contraire à
constituer des réserves telles que il a
été constitué à cet effet en 2001
puisque finalement le rendement de ce
fond est supérieur au coût de la dette
en tout cas encore aujourd'hui merci
merci
albéric de Montgolfier merci
meilleurs vœux à chacune et chacun
d'entre vous Monsieur le Directeur
Général en tant que ancien maire
d'Arcueil
évidemment une tendresse pour la Caisse
des Dépôts et Consignation qui fut la
première entreprise de mon territoire et
aussi pour les coopérations que j'ai eu
lorsque j'étais à la métropole du Grand
Paris avec cDC Biodiversité mais je
voudrais vous poser deux questions et
puis faire un commentaire léger la
première question je m'associe au
remarques qui ont trait à la situation
du logement social l'indexation des
prêts au HLM crée des situations de
tension très difficile et comme par
ailleurs le logement social ne bénéficie
pas de la part de notre gouvernement
d'une attention particulière et que
l'occasion du PLF ici nous n'avons pas
voté beaucoup de mesures en sa faveur je
voudrais savoir comment vous vous
regardez cette situation et la
possibilité de soutenir ces organismes
de logement social dans la période
actuelle la deuxième question porte vous
avez souligné l'importance de l'épargne
populaire je voudrais faire une critique
sur le ldds dont dont qui ne finance
finalement
cassé peu de projets écologique et
socialement responsable et qui au fond
pour beaucoup d'épargnants apparaît
comme un comme un produit qui me donne
aucune garantie d'un investissement or
vous savez il y a une attention dans la
société d'ailleurs vous êtes intervenu
longuement sur ce sujet et beaucoup de
gens aimeraient que leur épargne soit
utilisé réellement pour la transition
écologique personnellement ce terme me
convient mais la transformation me
convient parfaitement également donc
j'aimerais savoir quelle mesure sont
possibles de prendre et puis dans le
cadre du futur produit d'épargne vert
dont j'ai compris que la CD7 est mandaté
par la loi pour le gérer quel serait les
critères d'exclusion à y appliquer pour
que ce soit réellement un fond vert ma
troisième remarque c'est une remarque je
ne sais pas si vous êtes au courant vous
êtes propriétaire à Arcueil du site
historique l'ancien collège Albert
Legrand où est né la devise olympique si
tu Celsius Fortus à vrai dire c'est une
page de publicité en direction de mes
collègues
sous l'égide du pèredidan et j'espère
que la caisse prendra des initiatives à
l'occasion des JO à Paris pour valoriser
cet événement historique Arcueil étant
chacun de celles au centre du monde tout
autant que la gare de Perpignan et c'est
à l'homme de culture que j'adresse ce
commentaire
merci Daniel et bien alberry de
Montgolfier a ouvert cette je mettrai
aussi
une réserve sur Arcueil pour moi
représente le centre des examens et des
mauvais souvenirs chaque fois
sciences
le matin à 8h avec le monsieur le
directeur général vous avez fait indiqué
que la transition écologique se fait
partie des priorités de la Caisse des
Dépôts une question très simple sur le
déploiement des bornes de recharge
notamment en zone urbaine voilà c'est
sans doute relativement facile à
domicile la Caisse des Dépôts annonçait
l'initiative je crois à travers la
banque des territoires est-ce que vous
en dire plus sur le moyen d'aider les
collectivités à développer déployer des
bornes de recharge pour assurer
notamment la transition écologique en
matière de véhicules notamment en zone
urbaine merci beaucoup
merci Monsieur le Directeur général il
vous revient maintenant en 15 minutes de
répondre à l'ensemble de ces
interrogations c'est du 15 minutes à peu
près évidemment plutôt 13 bien c'est
directeur nous écouter Président c'est
vraiment là où je regrette de pas avoir
bénéficié des cours dispensés à l'ENA
mais je vais faire au mieux
sur les questions du sénateur Hervé
Moret sur les questions de ma salariale
et d'intéressement la masse salariale
elle a augmenté d'abord parce que nos
missions ont augmenté le triplement des
investissements de la banque des
territoires le nouveau mandat confié par
l'État sur mon compte formation le
développement des activités que j'ai
évoquées ça s'est traduit par une
augmentation des effectifs et nous
mesurons très attentivement année après
année le contrôle de la commission de
surveillance le rapport de cette
augmentation des effectifs par rapport
aux augmentations de l'activité et nous
avons fait de la productivité à hauteur
de 1,5 à 2% par an c'est à dire que nous
informatisons nous améliorons
l'efficacité et donc de ce côté là
on va essayer de faire mieux mais c'est
quelque chose à quoi nous sommes
attentifs l'augmentation de la masse
salariale c'est aussi l'augmentation de
la rémunération des agents et là nous
suivons les règles de en public de façon
totale puisque c'est la loi et puis nous
accompagnons de façon parallèle les
salariés du secteur privé alors
l'intéressement vous l'avez dit à juste
titre c'est pour tout le monde c'est
fait comme c'est fait pour ça en
revanche nous avons des mesures
individuelles qu'on appelle la PvE
variable sur l'objectif qui permet de
distinguer en fonction de l'attein des
objectifs de nos collaborateurs de façon
très organisée par la DRH avec des
entretiens annuels avec du suivi et donc
il y a évidemment une part individuelle
à la fois dans cette part variable et
aussi dans les évolutions de
rémunération et de parcours de de nos
agents donc de ce côté là il me semble
qu'on applique une méthode de gestion de
nos équipes qui est qui est moderne
alors
quand la cour pardon je viens le
deuxième élément de votre question que
dit que la place de la banque des
territoires reste
marginal encore une fois 2 milliards
d'investissements dans les territoires
dans les communes qui avec un de levier
de 7 peu dégager
plus de 12 à 14 milliards d'euros
d'investissement
territorialisés je suis pas sûr que ce
sont complètement marginal je rappelle
que l'investissement des collectivités
locales chaque année c'est de l'ordre de
80 à 85 milliards d'euros donc c'est une
contribution qui est pas marginale
comment la faire évoluer positivement en
réalité je crois la voir montrer les
fonds sont disponibles
il nous faudrait plus de projets et ça
c'est une alliance entre les élus locaux
notamment les maires les présidents de
de collectivités de communauté de
communes et nous-mêmes et c'est ce que
nous faisons en étant le plus possible
le moteur pour pour originel des
investissements
alors c'est le sénateur Canivet oui bien
sûr les énergies renouvelables c'est
partout même les hydroliennes par
exemple dans le passage de la jument qui
voilà dans votre département ou dans
d'autres endroits et c'est clair que
nous sommes très ouverts sur j'ai cité
que les principaux thèmes mais mais sur
les innovations en cours il y a
l'hydrolien il y a tout ce qui est lié à
l'hydrogène avec des usines de
construction d'hydrogène vers parce que
l'hydrogène fabriquée à partir de
charbon franchement c'est évidemment
quelque chose qui qui ne va pas du tout
en revanche on a de plus en plus
d'éléments à partir de l'hydrogène vert
de méthanisation on travaille avec le
monde agricole de façon à ce que la
méthanisation soit une source de
d'énergie et donc c'est des événements
sur le sur lequel nous sommes attendus
alors il y a eu beaucoup de questions
sur le logement social
ouvert par le sénateur Lefebvre et c'est
vrai que
le secteur du logement social et j'ai
passé trois jours au Congrès HLM qui
s'est tenu près de Lyon il y a quelques
mois
efface à des bouleversements importants
puisque il y a la hausse du taux du
livret A qui va se poursuivre puisque
parce que l'inflation elle est taux
d'intérêt monte il y a la hausse du coup
des matières premières pour la
construction ou la rénovation et puis il
y a aussi la hausse du coût de l'énergie
qui pèse surtout d'ailleurs sur les
locataires mais mais pas seulement donc
il y a des défis absolument massifs
alors nous accompagnons par des mesures
très diverses d'abord il y a ce qu'on
appelle la double révisabilité qui fait
que quand le taux du livret A monte il y
a un étalement
accrue du remboursement alors vous êtes
des financiers ça ne change pas l'impact
sur le résultat des bailleurs en
revanche ça a un impact important sur
leur trésorerie qui est allégé et
c'était demandé pour le fils de laine je
sais pas si c'est de l'opale dont vous
parlez ou d'un autre fils c'est l'opale
bien connu qui est un office absolument
remarquable d'engagement nous pouvons
aussi ajouter
un travail sur
l'échéancier de remboursement et donc on
peut modifier la courbe de remboursement
en différence et remboursements afin de
soutenir tel Office qui en aurait besoin
j'ai entendu
je l'ai noté dire que nous ne faisions
pas de taux fixe en fait compte tenu de
l'évolution des temps et des taux nous
avons mis en place une offre de tofix de
8 milliards d'euros donc c'est
considérable une première qui est
financée par la section générale donc
par le la Caisse des Dépôts canal
historique et puis nous travaillons sur
une autre qui sera financé par ce film
parce que c'est une un élément de
réponse et donc à l'évidence nous allons
développer et puis je veux pas être trop
long enfin même si je suis intéressé sur
le sujet nous avons mis en place aussi
des mesures de soutien extrêmement
puissantes avec des prêts participatifs
c'est prêt participatif en fait c'est du
quasi capital à des conditions
extrêmement subventionnelles nous avons
mis une première tranche de 1 milliard
d'euros ces éléments sont tellement
subventionnels que je peux vous dire que
dans nos comptes 2022 nous devons
provisionner sur les propriétés qui ont
été accordées de l'ordre de 175 millions
d'euros
donc c'est un élément de soutien très
important et nous avons mis en place une
deuxième tranche de 250 millions d'euros
de préparatifs et c'est prêt sont
alloués en priorité aux petits
organismes aux offices parce que
évidemment les grands ESH adossés à des
acteurs capitalistiques ou plus
puissants n'ont pas besoin de notre aide
et d'ailleurs ne le demande pas
pardon
sur les outre-mer ça ne joue pas
monsieur le sénateur parce que plus de
la moitié des organismes de logement
social des Outre-mer plus de la moitié
sont maintenant détenus par celles et
habitats et donc nous allons dans le
capital qui va bien et j'ai visité
beaucoup de ces logements que ce soit
Saint-Laurent-du-Maroni en Guadeloupe à
Saint-Denis de la Réunion qui ont été
rénovés on a investi des centaines de
millions d'euros véritablement des
centaines de millions d'euros pour
rétablir la qualité des logements dans
les outre-mer et une autre partie c'est
détenu par Action Logement qui en a
aussi les moyens donc vous avez raison
mais encore une fois c'est dans la ligne
de ce que j'ai dit c'est vraiment dédié
vers
vers les organismes qui en ont besoin
alors sur la deuxième vie du bâtiment
aujourd'hui on est sur des tests qui
sont en train d'être fait pour vérifier
si on peut mettre en place un dispositif
plus plus durable alors ça Valley sur la
poste
je vais essayer d'être bref monsieur le
Président mais mais c'est une question
très importante que que vous portez le
timbre rouge c'est 1,5%
1,5% du courrier le volume de lettre est
passé de 18 milliards d'euros chaque
année à 6 milliards d'euros l'année
dernière donc une baisse absolument
massive et en réalité le timberon rouge
non seulement c'est devenu très marginal
mais le maintien du timbre rouge obligé
à La Poste à maintenir des Lignières
donc avec un bilan carbone désastreux
pour faire les transversales Nice Brest
envoyé les timbres rouges et aussi un
réseau de transport
qui est écouté pour un service en
réalité pour trois lettres par an alors
que les offres alternatives permettent
de rendre le service de mandée avec le
même en répondant en faisant des
Français nous maintenons le sénateur
nous maintenons enfin la Poste maintient
parce que mais nous sommes principales
actionnaires effectivement nous
maintenons le principe prévu par la loi
d'une tournée 6
jours alors évidemment quand il y a pas
de courrier à mettre dans la boîte aux
lettres le facteur ne passe pas dans la
cage d'escalier mais il passe dans la
rue 6 jours sur 7 nous sommes le seul
pays à des seuls pays d'Europe à
maintenir ce principe et c'est pour ça
que nous faisons la transformation de La
Poste pour que au lieu de réduire le
nombre de tourner ce que nous ne faisons
pas nous augmentions les services rendus
par les facteurs en leur permettant de
livrer des services à domicile d'aller
veiller sur les personnes âgées d'aller
distribuer éventuellement des éléments
permettant de soigner les gens donc ça
reste un modèle de proximité ça reste un
modèle du quotidien simplement nous
devons faire face à la baisse des
revenus à l'augmentation des coûts et je
rappelle que c'est un grand service
public qui pour la mission de service
public est soutenue par l'État ce qui
est normal mais qui pour le reste réussi
à financer soi-même sa transformation
grâce à l'énergie à l'engagement des
posters et des postiers ok d'ailleurs je
veux rendre hommage ici et donc cette
transformation elle est le fait de
impact économique qui s'impose à nous
mais encore une fois nous souhaitons
maintenir les 17000 points de contact et
la tournée du facteur 6 jours sur 7 à
cet égard vous nous demandez quelle est
la doctrine d'actionnaire public
d'abord il y a une part d'héritage si je
puis dire Transdev était une entité
détenue par la Caisse des Dépôts alors
effectivement il y a une bizarie
Française d'avoir trois grands acteurs
publics pendant la question c'est
comment est-ce qu'on fait mouvement dans
ce cadre la question elle est pas
totalement simple on nous avons trois
grandes institutions publiques qui se
développent chacune de leurs côtés après
si vous évoquez le modèle Stuart Stuart
c'est différent tu vois c'est la pause
qui est maintenant une société anonyme
qui diversifie son activité précisément
pour faire face à la baisse du courrier
et on sait bien que la Poste développe
des activités concurrentielles et c'est
tout à fait normal je dirais d'ailleurs
que la caisse aussi je n'en ai parlé
dans mon introduction développe des
activités concurrentielles puisque les
textes le code moteur est financier nous
permet d'avoir soit des activités
publiques soit également des activités
dans le domaine concurrentiel et nous le
faisons avec parcimonie sous le contrôle
de la commission de surveillance et
évidemment
la liberté de parole et je la respecte
totalement mais parler de la Caisse des
Dépôts comme une banque capitaliste
sachant que nous n'avons pas
l'actionnaire
nous n'avons des rémunérations qui
restent disons peut-être élevé pour le
secteur public mais on peut enlever un
ou deux zéro par rapport à ce qu'il y a
dans le secteur privé et que notre seul
intérêt à agir c'est l'intérêt général
voilà je me permets de contester cette
voilà mais dans le cas d'un débat amical
citez mon livre évidemment je revendique
les propos que que vous citez parce que
parce que
c'est vrai que je plaide pour une
transformation du capitalisme afin qu'il
soit plus équitable et qu'il accompagne
la transformation énergétique notamment
alors vous parlez du niveau dans le
résultat mais heureusement nous avons
des résultats puisque nous n'avons pas
d'actionnaire puisque nous n'avons pas
d'actionnaires et que les fonds propres
les 60 milliards de fonds propres
accumulés c'est les résultats que mes
prédécesseurs ont pu dégager depuis 1816
et c'est sur la base de ces fonds
propres que nous nous pouvons prêter
investir développer le pays et en fait
pour nous le profit si je puis dire
n'est pas un objectif c'est une
condition de survie
et d'ailleurs ces profits sont tout à
fait modestes si vous voulez comparez
encore une fois au fond propre engagé ce
qui est normal puisque notre coup du
capital est moindre alors pardon je n'ai
pas dit que chaque euro de la caisse
allait aller vers le logement social
parce que là dans ces cas-là ce serait
une rupture avec notre mandat je dis que
chaque euro doit être engagé dans la
transformation écologique et sociale
parce que quand nous finançons des
énergies renouvelables quand nous
finançons le très haut débit dans les
territoires ruraux et bien c'est pas du
logement social mais je pense que sont
des choses utiles je reviendrai sur vos
propos sur le livret vert parce qu'il y
a eu d'autres questions sur le
le
sur le ldds alors oui c'est le sénateur
Vincent Hublet qui parlait du coup de la
dette et du taux fixe mais mais oui
monsieur le sénateur c'est une
préoccupation l'évolution du taux du
livret A et évidemment et nous y
travaillons pour veiller en lycée les
effets je me permets de rappeler à cet
écart que évidemment nous connaissons
très bien les plus de 500 organ de
logements social qui sont nous
partenaires et dont la situation
d'ensemble est solide
les difficultés sont réelles mais la
capacité financière à construire elle
est là
alors madame la sénatrice Vanina Pauly
Gaga sur les forêts et la biodiversité
alors en fait c'est biodiversité
s'occupent plutôt de biodiversité et la
forêt c'est pas tellement dans ce mandat
mais c'est plutôt dans le mandat de la
société forestière ou de dans le mandat
de tout ce que nous faisons pour ces
adaptations parce qu'on sait que la
forêt française est soumise à des défis
importants et nous nous voulons
accompagner et donc au travers de la
société forestière ou ou des équipes de
la banque des territoires on a
évidemment des moyens et d'ingénierie
pour cela alors sur l'industrie verte
vous avez raison nous sommes dans une
compétition qui est devenue beaucoup
plus difficile avec les États-Unis
depuis que l'inflation réduction Act
pardon pour la qualité de l'anglais
a été décidé par le président Biden et
nous résistons très vaillamment nous
résistons travailler avant nous avons
deux giga Factory de piles de batterie
pour voiture que les financement l'une à
Denain l'une à Douai pardon et et
l'autre à Dunkerque et nous travaillons
avec le gouvernement pour que nous ayons
une capacité de réaction pour attirer
les
usines mais vous avez raison nous sommes
en défense en ce moment et il faut
absolument que nous reprenions le foncif
et moi j'y tiens enfin sur le timing
pour les ressources d'ingénierie vous
avez raison nous sommes d'autant plus
longs que sur les petites villes nous
avons dû mettre en place une procédure
intermédiée le plus souvent par les
Conseils départementaux qui ont fait
d'ailleurs un très bon travail moi dans
les choses sont en place et ça
fonctionne ça fonctionne mieux
tu le sénateur patient merci de votre
commentaire positif sur ce que nous ont
dans les outre-mer j'ai eu de dire
l'occasion de me rendre moi-même en
Guyane pour voir la réalisation de nos
objectifs alors c'est vrai que la
direction de la plaque territoriale est
située comme vous le rappelez en
Guadeloupe nous avons néanmoins à
Cayenne des équipes permanentes qui sont
sur le terrain qui sont à vos côtés qui
sont aux côtés des élus et qui ont
pouvoir de décision donc c'est vrai que
il y a un historique mais mais vous avez
raison la Guyane est
une région où nous investissons très
fortement d'ailleurs on a signé
récemment un aquaprede de mémoire de 23
millions d'euros pour améliorer
l'adduction d'eau dans dans la région et
nous allons naturellement continuer à
investir et vous pouvez compter sur
notre soutien
alors Monsieur Cozic sur l'arrêté
d'intérim je suis pas moi-même un
juriste il me semble qu'il y avait ni
absence ni en pèchement ni vacances et
donc l'État a considéré que l'intérim
assuré par moi-même danse effectivement
une configuration qui n'était pas
explicitement prévue puisque la loi
pacte n'évoquait pas les cas de
renouvellement du directeur général
et donc ça a été organisé comme ça
voilà il ne dépend que de votre décision
que cette vacances de courte durée ou
plutôt cet intérim soit de cours de
durée
mais mais voilà ce que je peux dire
alors madame vermeiller le fond de
réserve des retraites mais merci de
poser cette question merci de saluer la
performance du fond de réserve des
retraites qui est un élément intéressant
dans le débat public parce que c'est un
fond décidé par l'État placé sous
l'autorité de l'État et qui dès lors
qu'il a une vision très long terme a été
investie majoritairement solutions et en
Action française et ça montre bien ce
que nos concitoyens ne savent pas assez
comme élément de complément de
préparation de la retraite c'est que
investir en action c'est dans la longue
durée un investissement qui est un
investissement favorable alors
évidemment le fond de la réserve d'après
quand tu de la qualité des agents et des
salariés qui travaillent le fait de
façon très méthodique mais c'est vrai
que ces performances sont bonnes alors
est-ce que il devrait faire autre chose
que rembourser la dette et bien madame
le sénatrice ce n'est pas moi qui fait
des lois je les respecte et donc dès
lors que le Parlement de la République a
décidé cela nous le mettons en oeuvre
mais au-delà du clin d'oeil moi je
souhaiterais que ce fond puisse
continuer à produire ses effets en fait
il a été très utilisé pour des raisons
de plus court terme ce qui est dommage
par rapport à l'ambition initiale et si
on pouvait retrouver l'ambition initiale
de se projeter dans la longue durée
comme un fond d'accompagnement des
sujets de retraite dans j'ai cru
comprendre aujourd'hui qu'il allait
occupé la République je pense que ce
serait une bonne chose
alors sur le long terme l'année dernière
a été compliqué quand tu es de la hausse
des toits et de la baisse mais sur le
long terme il est supérieur à 4% depuis
les les il a dû être créé il y a 20 ou
25 ans 25 ans je crois
alors je crois monsieur le sénateur
brayait à avoir parlé du du logement
social mais en répétant nous sommes très
attachés à maintenir le rythme de
construction qui dépend beaucoup des
élus naturellement mais mais que nous
nous souhaitons convaincre et aussi de
maintenir le rythme de transformation
énergétique des logements qui d'ailleurs
étaient aussi un service rendu au
locataire donc ça fait baisser la
facture et s'améliore la qualité du du
logement alors sur l'épargne populaire
et sur les fonds du livret de
développement durable et solidaire le
premier accord que j'ai signé ayant été
nommé il y a 5 ans c'était à Bercy avec
le gouvernement pour veiller à ce que la
collecte nouvelle des déesses soit
fléchés vers la transformation
écologique et de façon générale
l'ensemble des engagements des fonds
d'épargne sont engagés vers la
transformation écologique soit parce que
nous financements des logements qui
naturellement sont des logements verts
où nous faisons de la rénovation
thermique ou nous finançons la
transformation du pays donc
effectivement il n'y a pas de
cantonnement comme on dit c'est à dire
que dans l'organisation des fonds
d'épargne et ça c'est les textes qui le
prévoit
il y a pas de suivi Europa euro de ce
qui arrive sur tel produit financier et
comment cet investi mais même s'il y a
pas de fléchage l'eau nous veillons à ce
que la collecte nette nouvelle sur le
ldds soit à l'euro l'euro engagé dans
des projets écologiques et ça nous
pouvons le montrer je peux vous donner
j'ai ici la liste des projets concernés
donc je pense que nous sommes dans notre
mandat dans la façon dont nous gérons
cet exercice le ministre souhaite
réfléchir à un projet qui soit encore
plus ciblé en réalité ces réflexions
commencent donc je ne peux pas dévoiler
quels sont les idées que le ministre
avec la direction générale du Trésor va
proposer naturellement nous y
travaillerons avec lui parce que c'est
notre rôle et je veux vous remercier
d'avoir évolu d'avoir évoqué le site
d'Arcueil de la Caisse des Dépôts
effectivement
les Jeux olympiques sont évoqués avec la
fameuse formule et un terrain absolument
magnifique sur lequel évidemment en
relation avec les élus nous allons
veiller à ce que ce développement
sincère dans le développement de la
ville enfin dernier point j'aurai un peu
débordé monsieur le Président mais il y
a un foisonnement très riche de
questions pour répondre au dernier point
du sénateur Albert de Montgolfier pour
le développement des installations de
recherche de véhicules électriques les
irve
pour le moment il y a un foisonnement
je sais que l'État réfléchi à la façon
de mieux encadrer ce développement et il
me semble que ce serait bienvenu parce
que nous savons que nous avons en France
un vrai savoir-faire sur ces grandes
questions d'infrastructures et de
rénovation de nos méthodes nos modes de
transport et et en l'occurrence de
recharge de nouveaux véhicules
électriques qui sont les véhicules de
demain qui que les textes prévoient les
textes prévoient la rivière rapide mais
c'est vrai que les règles pourraient
être clarifiées et peut-être
pourraient-on faire ce qu'on a fait pour
le trait au débit et avoir différents
types de zones des zones où les acteurs
privés naturellement trouvent une
rentabilité qu'il est mobilise on est
par exemple correctionnaire de
différentes entités qui mettent des
ombrières sur les parkings de
supermarché ou autre mais sans doute
faudrait-il mieux organiser
territorialement c'est développement et
je peux vous dire que nous nous
choisissons et nous y travaillons déjà
voilà monsieur le Président en ayant
essayé d'être aussi rapide que possible
merci Monsieur le Directeur général je
vais donner à titre exceptionnel la
parole à Jérôme Bachard à condition que
ce ne soit pas une question ce n'est pas
une question c'était juste pour
témoigner avec Viviane qui est présent
que dans notre mission de commissaire
surveillant et avec Claude précédemment
nous pouvons travailler en confiance en
transparence avec le directeur général
c'est une chose importante quand on
parle commission de surveillance
le courant passe bien dans les deux
côtés
merci
Jérôme monsieur directeur général
ce directeur général nous allons d'abord
vous remercier
pour votre exposé liminaire pour vos
réponses
complètes et argumentées
nous savons évidemment que cet
après-midi vous serez auditionné par
l'Assemblée nationale pour le même sujet
bien entendu nous allons donc maintenant
vous demander de vous retirer nous
allons vous accompagner en vous
remerciant encore une fois et nous
allons pouvoir passer maintenant au vote
bonne journée à vous